die meisten zusendungen herr lauterbach
haben wir zum thema impfstoff bekommen
das ist das was die menschen tatsächlich
am meisten bewegt was ist mit dem
impfstoff und da gibt es ganz ganz viele
fragen die gekommen sind und ich möchte
ihnen eine zeigen von thomas arnold dem
nicht gefällt das in deutschland beim
thema tod im stoff man mal wieder
hinterher hängt er sagt wann konkret
wird der tod impfstoff in deutschland
kommen die eu zulassung läuft ja bereits
seit einiger zeit und deutschland hat
sich auch bereits 200 millionen dosen
tod im stoff gesichert in österreich
soll laut den medien schon geimpft
werden ja also deutschland plötzlich
keine 200 millionen dosen tor dem stoff
also gesichert sondern deutlich
geringere mengen der tod im stoff also
von salva und nova wachs ist in der
zulassung bei nowaks erwarte ich die
zulassung morgen wir haben also nowaks
impfstoff auch also haben wir bestellt
aber ich warne davor beim tod im stoff
also zu erwarten dass das also wie man
sie heutzutage sagt ein game changer
wäre das ist er sicherlich nicht es ist
aber viele menschen sind verunsichert
vom impfstoff und an das wäre derjenige
den sie nehmen alles gut da das ist auch
wichtig und daher haben wir auch droht
dem stoff und wir werden ihnen auch
gerne einsetzen das ist gar keine frage
der tod im stoff den wir bekommen alles
gut der impfstoff aber man muss offen
sein von den studien die wir jetzt haben
also wie ich stark wirken jetzt
beispielsweise impfstoffe bei einer
booster impfung dann muss man auch
realistischer weise einräumen dass diese
klassischen messenger jahre nach ihm
stoffe insbesondere moderne aber auch
bei und dass sie dann doch noch eine
ganze spur wirksamer sind so dass wir
nicht hier in eine falsche kommunikation
in einem geraten dass wir jetzt
impfstoffe bessere impfstoffe bekennen
die wir vorher nicht gehabt dann aber
ich kenne und verstehe viele menschen
wollen problemstoffe und praktika ja
genau die werden sie auch bekommen das
ist also das sind noble also impfstoffe
von daher das werden wir bringen haben
wir bestellt aber keine 200 millionen
großes thema für unsere zuschauern und
zuschauer auch die frage der impfpflicht
und insbesondere bewegt hat viele was er
kann chef lothar wieler im spiegel
gesagt hat zu den plänen das will ich
ihnen einmal zeigen er hat gesagt ich
glaube dass es immer noch der bessere
weg ist die menschen davon zu überzeugen
sich impfen zu lassen eine pflicht
sollte das letzte mittel sein wenn alle
anderen ausgeschöpft sind und gerade vor
dem hintergrund der lauterbacher sie
haben die debatte in dieser woche
aufgemacht es gab nicht genügend
impfstoff laut ihrer aussage für die
booster kampagne warum diskutieren dann
alle überleben also zunächst zum
impfstoffmangel uns ist es ja gelungen
als bundesregierung noch 25 millionen
dosen moderner impfstoff zu beschaffen
das war eine sehr wichtige beschaffung
weil mittlerweile ist es so dass das
impfstoff angebot so für den nachkauf
wegen der bedrohlichen omikron variante
also es gibt so gut wie nichts mehr das
heißt wir haben da noch ganz knapp im
stoff besorgen können ich bin nicht
sicher ob das eine woche später noch
gelungen wäre was mit dem fliegt jetzt
komme ich zu endlich nur dass das also
also war ich bin zum teil kritisiert
worden also für diese kampagne dem stoff
zu besorgen ich wage mir gar nicht
auszudenken was gewesen wäre wenn wir in
der nächsten woche wo viele leute hat
impfstoffe haben die union hat gesagt
ich hab immer genügend genau das war ich
nicht und das war schlicht und
ergreifend falsch also wenn die 25
millionen jetzt nicht gekommen wären
wären wir in einen engpass geraten und
das muss auch klar gesagt wenn ich bin
immer für klare worte und das muss ja
nochmal artikuliert darüber habe ich
mich geärgert ich hab ja tatsächlich
niemandem etwas vorgeworfen und möchte
das auch weiterhin nicht tun aber ich
lasse mich ungern kritisieren na ja sie
haben gesagt das nicht für den impfstoff
gibt ja aber seit der indirekten vorwurf
an den gesundheitsminister
damals konnte man ja möglicherweise auch
die omikron also wer noch nicht so sehen
soll aber geschenkt der impfstoff ist da
wir werden so eine kampagne laufen jetzt
so endlich ich will hier nicht auslassen
ich bin also hier anderer meinung als
also diejenigen die sagen es geht ohne
eine impfpflicht nehmen sie auch anderer
meinung ist lothar wieler hat er gesagt
habe wir müssen das alle anderen
mitlauschen hat sich so wie er es jetzt
also
ausgedrückt hat also weiß ich nicht aber
jetzt für dagegen daneben steht dass wir
alle anderen
möglichkeiten erst ausschöpfen der
meinung bin ja auch ich der unterschied
ist nur der ich glaube dass wir an dem
punkt angekommen zu entweder wir haben
ja sehr geringen also zuwachs noch bei
den erst kämpften und was ich einfach
vermeiden will ist dass wir bei jeder
neuen welle immer wenn neue variante
kommt dass wir dann quasi das ganze land
runterfahren müssen um zu verhindern
dass die ungeimpften so schwer erkranken
dass wir also sich schützen müssen und
dass wir möglicherweise dann sogar auch
also in eine situation kommen dass wir
ungeimpfte also
und erkrankte behandeln müssen und
andere menschen nicht intensiv
medizinisch versorgen können das ist
einfach nicht akzeptabel halten und ich
will ihn mal die meinung von unserem
zuschauer alexander sattelmaier zeigen
der hat nämlich gesagt nein ist es
längst noch nicht gemacht worden er sagt
ich bin kein impfgegner aber strikt
gegen die impfpflicht denn ich warte
noch auf einen tod im stoff und finde es
ungerecht jetzt alle zu impfungen zu
verdonnern wir haben noch so viele
menschen und auch mediziner bedenken
der tournee impfstoff wird ja jetzt
kommen er konnte ja vorher nicht
angeboten werden weshalb weil er noch
nicht zugelassen war und da hoffen wir
tatsächlich noch eine bewegung zu sehen
aber bei der sehr muss ab morgen ist die
erste sorgen ich rechne morgen mit der
zulassung von nowaks
und die also wenn wir hier also in die
perspektive hineinschauen die der
verlauf ist ja zum teil schon also nicht
ungefährlich bei denjenigen die noch
keine booster impfung haben aber bei den
ungeimpften müssen wir haben schwere
verläufe erwarten und also so eine hohe
zahl von ungeimpften ist schwierig also
die also epidemiologen die sich jetzt
also damit beschäftigt haben welche
länder in europa werden unter omikron
besonders leiten wir haben quasi länder
miteinander verglichen sie kommen zu dem
ergebnis dass
deutschland vielleicht sogar ein
besonderes problem haben könnte weil wir
einen so hohen an von ungeimpften haben
und das halte ich für nicht vertretbar